plus c'est un peu compliqué mais le
meilleur élève pour moi c'est gilles
verdez qui est une vraie révélation pour
son retour au quai beaucoup plus calme
et qu'il est extrêmement pertinente j'ai
beaucoup de j'ai beaucoup d'estimé et
d'admiration pour lui parce que je
trouve qu'il a une prise de parole
facile et qu' il est souvent très
pertinent et le moins bon élève
s'il faut le dire il faut être moi en
fait franchement je suis pas à l'aise
donc non je vous dirais moi parce que
j'ai rien à gérer à reprocher à
quiconque à cette table donc je trouve
que tout le monde est content on sait
pas on dit montiel c'est une bonne
équipe c'est une équipe c'est une super
équipe alors meilleurs élèves pour moi
s'il cherchait pour moi ça a toujours
été une des meilleures élèves font c'est
pas un honneur venant de ma part mais en
tout cas pour moi tu as été une des
meilleures et plus mauvais élèves c'est
bernard montiel mais vraiment sans
hésiter sus boules de la terre tu sais
pas quoi dire sur des mots qui sortent
nulle part de son cerveau il est
insupportable gym c'est vraiment le plus
nul c'est pourquoi parce que ça s'est
mal passé tout à l'heure en loge mais
voulait mais quand même mais je les
adore en tout cas ça soit vous savez
recevoir vos habits non mais vraiment ça
qui les bons choix en attaque mes amis
bâtonnier marquer alors pour moi c'est
gilles verdez le meilleur oui et non
parce que là tout aussi les bonnes infos
il est percutant et
il n'a pas sa langue dans sa poche et il
y va c'est bon et le moins bon élève et
ben c'est moi vraiment et bah si si si
c'est moi je suis la moins expérimentée
même chauffer c'est moi franchement
c'est fini ça voyez pas là franchement
sachez que des anciens jamais un ancien
de se désignera lui-même verte est pour
moi la meilleure elle survole l'année
c'est kelly kelly parce que quand elle
parle la lumière arrive pas au cauchemar
[Rires]
avec fatou parce qu'elle a des arguments
pertinents parce que sauf qu'après ses
tubes non non je trouve voilà qu'elle
est excellente et dès qu'elle est là
c'est différent donc c'est kelly et
kelly tu le croises ce qu'il vient de
dire mais on a un truc il est moi ah bon
jaloux un an loin d'aix est loin d'être
sexuelle faut le savoir
isabelle au gilbert des le pire oui
c'est montiel franchement cyril vous
adore mais comment faites vous pour le
faire venir chaque fois rejetées avait
été testé que j'adore j'adore bernard
boutiana j'aime la vie oui c'est mon
petit chouchou oui mais c'est le roi des
branleurs il ne travaille jamais y
arriver ne sais même pas ce qu'il va
dire oui c'est le vide incarne
évidemment c'est la pire alors moi le
meilleur c'est guillaume genton lvp
choix logique
je suis même pas je suis pas d'accord
avec lui et ça arrive souvent le trouve
toujours pertinent étayé est toujours
calme d'accord a contrario parce que je
vais pas me désigner moi même parce que
vous savez pas que des fois je tourne
qu'à dire mais donc pour moi le pire
c'est gilles parce qu'il est toujours
surexcité et pour mille à côté ça me
gonfle toujours jeunes téléspectateurs
et 2h13 enfin conseils de classe et d'un
enfant qu'on a fait un conseil de classe
on a perdu deux chroniqueurs de guerre
ces dernières que va-t-il se passer et
de coeur c'est bernard l'accord merci
bernard monte alors pour moi les
meilleurs élèves c'est vraiment
guillaume genton d'accord il est
vraiment très bon il parle très bien il
est très clair c'est vrai que c'est
souvent les nouveaux les meilleurs
élèves
il est très bien elle est très claire il
faut le garder et
vous croyez qu'on vous écoute c'est pour
ça que je le dis comme m'écoute et le
plus mauvais alors j'ai lire moi je
travaille énormément mais j'arrive pas à
en placer une
c'est toujours un peu difficile c'est
regarder je travaille mais bon je trouve
qu elle toujours les autres s'expriment
mieux que moi donc je n'ose pas y aller
c'est vrai on sait qui est le plus
mauvais et ben moi alors vous pouvez pas
dire ça sinon moi j'ai du charme et j'ai
du charme mais ça n'a rien à voir
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]